[Music]
hi uh we're at the final stretch of the
conference right
there's a good part and a hard part of
it the good part is i can reference
the other folks that presented before me
the hard part is that i have to follow
them right
and
i mean we saw a flying drone controlled
with bananas am i right
now i have to talk about typescript
[Applause]
i'm i'm joking because i'm always
excited to talk about typescript
functional programming and board games
but i'm gonna stick to
typescript for today all right
and why well
it seems like these days on every
javascript conference there is at least
one person trying to sneak in some
typescript talk that's me today with a
good reason right yesterday we saw
during the type annotations talk that
there is there are a need for
for types right and i'm here trying to
uh
show you that typescript is doing a good
job at that
one other thing that we saw yesterday is
that we read a lot of code right we we
saw
that um
uh uncle bob said that there's a ratio
of reading to write code to of ten to
one
right that's a very very good um
a very good difference in time that we
spend doing one thing versus the other
one good example and is that when we're
trying to debug or find a bug in our
code and we spend hours and hours
reading throughout code just to have a
one line to fix the code anyone
right
that's a good show of that right and
many times that's the kind of experience
we have reading that code it's not a
very pleasant experience we spent a lot
of time reading the code trying to
understand you know other
one other thing that was said yesterday
by maureen is that
sometimes we don't even understand the
code that we wrote one year ago well i
don't agree with that because sometimes
i look at my code that i wrote about a
month ago and i don't understand it so
yeah
anyway i bet we all wanted to have an
experience like this one a pleasant
experience reading code so i'm here to
tell you that
with typescript
and a little bit of functional
programming we can achieve some of that
pleasant reading code
now
when i'm talking about typescript and if
you look at this screenshot of this old
version of the typescript website you're
gonna see something like this typescript
is a typed superset of javascript and
that's okay that helped typescript uh be
adopted a lot by javascript developers
right
but these days if you look at the
website you're going to see something
more like this what it says typescript
is a strong type programming language
and if you want to leverage the most of
what typescript has to offer we have to
see typescript as a strongly typed
programming language not just as a
superset of javascript and i'm going to
try to show a little bit the difference
of what those two mean
having said all that
i'm not gonna be talking about
typescript 101 this is not an
introduction so i want to raise your
hand if you never worked with typescript
and by work i mean pushed code super
production with typescript let me see if
i can see
not a lot of hands okay that's great but
for those of you right that don't have a
lot of experience with typescript
i don't want you to pay attention to how
you're gonna write that code i want you
to pay attention on what you can achieve
with what i'm trying to propose here
with this mindset
my name is thiago temple i am a staff
developer at shopify
i flew all the way from canada to be
here
thanks for the tip uh pages
i have a daughter named emma
she's turning seven today and she's back
home so
happy birthday emma
in the past i have produced a course on
functional programming with javascript
a course on how to get more from the
typescript compiler but today
this talk here is the combination of my
learnings of using other
strongly typed functional programming
languages
such as f-sharp not to be confused with
c-sharp although they both use the
dotnet framework
and elm which is a language that
its sole purpose is to develop
front-end applications
and it's both of them are fully
typed functional programming languages
all right we're going to talk a little
bit about
function signatures
we're going to talk a little bit about
the any type in typescript strings and
how we can better use them
what invalid object states are
and immutability
ready
all right
what is this function doing and when i'm
talking about that i'm talking about
function signatures right and the
importance of those
a function
be that in functional programming or
javascript is a piece of code that takes
an input
process that and returns an output
that's pretty much it
that's all we're talking about in terms
of that
if you look at this piece of code here
and this is
typescript
taking two numbers and returning another
number and we can infer that because the
name of this function is n and we're
taking two numbers right
now
if you look at this other function here
what you're seeing is a different story
you know what it's taking it's taking
two arguments order and other options
but what is returning
can you tell it just by glancing at this
function i can't
granted
our tools today you don't need to read
this one this is vs code the print
screen of vs code i mouse over that
function and i have
some help from vs code and vs code is
telling me
that
this function is highly returning a
string
or an instance of process order
or an instance of order action
okay
now there's a feature in typescript
which is
it infers the return type of functions
and that's what it's doing here and what
that means is it's going to look at the
body of the function and every time
there's a return
value it's going to infer to be one of
those possible values there
now i may be
explicitly wanting to return those or
that may be an accident did i really
want to return a string
i'm not sure but if i wanted to i could
create a type to communicate that
and for those who don't know this is
called a union type a union type means
that i have a type or the result here
that's the name of the type
and at any given point i either have an
instance of process order order action
or a string and now i am being explicit
and just with
with a single glance i can know that
this function is taking those two
arguments and returning an order result
right
now if i look at this type here i can
make it even better because string
looks a little bit odd there what i can
do is create what it's called the type
alias and i'm telling okay
that string means that i'm returning an
order processing error
and now that's clear part of my type i
know that whenever i have an error it's
going to be a string of course but it's
named there and people know why what to
expect when they just see that type
speaking of error handling
let's look at that function signature
again
can you tell me if this function
may throw an error
i don't know
just by looking at it i don't know
right
what i do know
is that i can avoid throwing exceptions
wait a minute i'm going to avoid
throwing exceptions how i'm going to
have error handling well let's get back
to functional programming in functional
programming we talk a lot about pure
functions and a pure function
b staying at a high level means that
i take an input i process some data and
i have an output
i always
follow that pattern right
what that means is
which is also a very common jargon in
functional programming i have no side
effects
and an exception
is a side effect
side effect because it's breaking that
flow of taking an input and returning an
output now that still doesn't solve how
i'm gonna handle an error well we can
solve that with a type
a generic type and again another union
type in this type here result i either
returning a success of a generic type t
result or an error of a generic type t
error and if i implement that type a
success is just a simple type with the
kind and the value of the success or a
failure is another type with another
kind and an error
of a different type okay
don't mind too much about the kind there
but the only important thing is that
they are
unique identifiers to each of those
types so i can know them and i'm going
to talk a little bit more of what that
means later the one consequence of that
now is that i have a type order result
that
is returning a result right and when
it's returning a result and it's
successful
i know that i'm going to either get a
processed order or another action but if
it fails
i know that i'm going to get another
processing error
and that is a string right
and all of that
just with a single glance
at the function signature
all right
the kind there that you saw because it
was present in both
the
success and the failure means the
typescript know that this type this
member exists in both types and now i
can inspect that regardless of being a
successful failure and then determine
okay if it is a failed result i have
access to the error and i can handle it
but if it's not
then i have access to the value and it's
either one of the two values that i am
expecting all that communicated and
ensured by typescript
okay
that's it so far one thing that i want
to mention that we saw earlier
by doing that we're being
predictable we saw on mata stock earlier
but we we are adding predictability to
our code right i forgot to
to to return to this point here when i'm
doing this
i know every time
that i am returning another result and
may fail
now
i don't know about you right but i don't
inspect every and single one of the
functions that i call to know if those
functions are going to throw an
exception right so and throw an
exception i'm removing the
predictability of my code but adding a
type that tells me that i may have a
failure it's adding to the
predictability and of course the
reliability of my code because i'm i'm
going to reduce the number of runtime
errors that i'm going to get later
because i forgot to see if there's a
exception being thrown
now talking about no
i know it's very interesting because no
can represent that a value was not found
no can represent that an error has
occurred
no can represented that an unpredicted
case has happened or that something
isn't required
or that a condition is falsy and even
more right so that means that no it's
very versatile right
wrong
no is hiding what i'm trying to tell in
my code no is a
problem
such a big problem that in functional
programming we heard a lot that the
inventor of the no value back in the 50s
called it
the billion dollar mistake
and if you
go it later we're gonna find
what that means no is a problem it's not
a solution so don't use no
ever
now if i'm not using no
how can i represent
that i don't have a value
well let me tell you one thing here if
you look at this function signature and
you have find user by id and you gotta
know as a result
right
what does it mean to you does it mean
that i couldn't find a user or does it
mean that an error has happened
no doesn't tell me anything about that
right
but an option type just like we saw the
result type will tell you sometimes
you're going to see this pattern called
maybe instead of option but an option is
telling me that i either have some value
with the kind and the value that is
carrying or no variable no value at all
with another kind here let's just
identifying what that type is i don't
have a value for this
now when i'm using this type here
to
indicate that i'm returning an option of
an user i'm telling the consumers of
this function here that if i don't have
a value you're gonna get a none
as a response but i'm telling everybody
this may happen
and you know that just with a single
glance
and once again because we have that kind
that is shared between the two
i can inspect and then use my user when
i need it
all right
before any water
and any
and it's very interesting right
any is the thing that can morph into
anything right and
we use a lot any when we just get into
typescript but here's a quote for you
don't use any as a catch offer types
you're unsure of also don't be lazy and
yes i'm coding myself here
when
i was using those two languages and i
used them as a full full-time
development like a shift code production
and all of that was not just a pet
project
they don't have the concept of any
that just doesn't exist
everything is typed and everything has
its own proper type right so it's
possible to do that
we reach out to any
very quickly in typescript land we don't
need to do that
but there are some valid use cases of
any right one of those is when you know
nothing about uh the given value that
you're typing as any and
you don't care about that value right
those cases it is valid
type card functions if you don't know
about type guard functions is a small
function that takes some arbitrary value
sometimes type as any and it makes some
checks to make sure that that given
value is of
a given type right you want to make sure
of that and sometimes you need to make
you take it any value
and some advanced generic constraints
which i'm not gonna get too much into
because they are advanced matt pock was
in the house here he's the guy to talk
to about advanced typescript
try to find him later
but if you're not in one of those
conditions i'm gonna say to you that you
should always default to use unknown an
unknown is a special type in typescript
that in some cases behavior
similarly to uh any with a different uh
very a couple a couple of different
things one it's conveying a different
message
when you have something type it type it
as any you're telling everybody okay i
can accept anything
when you when you type something as
unknown what you're telling your users
is that i don't know what the type is
eventually i might right now i don't
and in terms of the compiler there's
another difference right when you start
making assumptions of that unknown type
like my args here
i'm assuming that there may be some key
in there i get a compiler
and then i am required to type that it's
a generic type with the constraint
that my object may have or should have
some key
of type string
and then that's good so unknown is used
for that you might say okay i may have
other edge cases that you're not talking
about here maybe
i would argue that for most most cases
you can type but if you cannot type
with
something other than any
consider two things here uh
one if you type something like this here
a user with a rows of any and that's a
type or could be an interface right that
you are exporting and it's being used
across what you're telling everybody in
your across your code base is that
whenever you see a user roles can be
anything so that is a communication
spread around your entire code base as
if you do something like this
you are compartmentalizing where the any
is it's just inside of that function so
if you can't minimize the usage of any
try to do so because then you're keeping
that
in just a small portion of your code
all right
let's go and talk about strings and with
javascript we love to use strings from
many different things right
for instance let's look at this function
here and this function is
trying to find movies by a given genre
right and it's
typed as a string
and this is a good example of typescript
being a superset of javascript
of course snipe right
but if i call this function here
and i get an empty array back as a
result
do i know if
i didn't find movies for that genre or
did i pass the wrong string
i can tell just by that right
how can i solve this i can create a
union type whenever i have a finite set
of values i can create a union type and
now if i get an empty string back that
means that
i don't have movies for comedy right but
i cannot pass the wrong string to that
function so if i limit that i'm limiting
uh
my choices and i'm limiting the possible
errors that i may have
here's another example here
i have an order with many status
using another union type
and that status could be either new paid
shipped or completed right those are
clear there those are all the possible
statuses that i may have for an order so
people looking at this know what an
order can be
now
here's another benefit of doing that i
have a switch case handling that order
status right
and because i don't have a default
return here on my switch case and i am
explicitly returning a type typescript
is going to check for me that if i have
a value being returned at all possible
cases
uh on that branch here on that switch
statement
right
which means that if
in the future i add a new status let's
say pending
this is going to yield an error because
i'm not handling all possible cases
right typescript knows that and it's
going to ensure that another benefit of
that is what i'm communicating here by
having one specific case here for each
one of my
statuses and not having a default what
i'm telling the
people looking at this code is that
every single case needs to be handled
there is no
a couple of cases that are handled in a
way and then a default case that handles
all other cases so that's communication
i'm telling the users of the code okay
every single case needs to be handled
and if that's not the case then you can
group those cases together but by not
using the default i'm telling that to
folks
all right
let's talk about make invalid states
impossible to represent and
i cannot tell you if this comes from
functional programming but i learned
that while learning functional
programming languages and for me this is
the coolest part so if there's one thing
you want to take from the whole
presentation try to make this it's
probably the hardest one as well so
but let's try a little bit
i have a type here a tight payment
and it has an amount of type number
a member credit card info and the
question mark there means that this is
optional so i might have credit card
evil
i might have a paypal info which is also
optional or this payment here may be
made using cash right
now this here is a good representation
of
typescript again being a superset of
javascript why in javascript it's very
common that we hold information in
objects and we add members and
properties as we need as we go right
there's no
static type so that's what we do so this
is representing that the problem with
this type here is that this may happen
can i tell you how was this paid for
i cannot right but this is value type
script this compiles and this passes
it's
45 42
amount right it was not paid with cash
but i don't have the actual information
that i need to tell me how this payment
was made so how can i fix that
one don't use optional
arguments and make this payment info a
required a member of the payment type
and now i have payment info there right
and by doing that now i can create a
union type payment info that can tell me
that this is going to be either paid by
credit card paypal or cash but now this
is required and part of the type and
compiled
or checked at compile time
in my type by now you understand this i
have a kind for each one of those if i
have a credit card i may have extra
fields such a number of the credit card
expiration date and so on so far paypal
info same idea and cash is just pure
simply a type cash right i don't need to
know any extra information
that means now that when i have an
instance of a payment type
i do need to inform the payment info it
is required and because it's required i
have to also inform all members of the
given kind uh that i chose to use or was
used by the user when created that
payment right i have a credit credit
card info
and a number so again i am communicating
to everybody that payment always need
the extra payment if payment info
one other example i have an order with
an order id
a billing address both required and an
optional shipping address right question
mark optional
why
why may i not have a shipping address
here
again i may look at an instance of an
order and not tell you like i don't have
the shipping address what's the reason
for that
i don't know
but if my shipping is required my ship
with the shipping type and once again i
have a union type to define that
i can tell you that my shipping may
either be
same as
billing so i don't need an extra that
duplicated information or i'm selling
something that is just a digital content
so i don't need to ship it or if it is a
shipping address
then i may have the address for that
let's look at those types once again
right union types with their unique
kinds and just for the shipping address
i have the address
again about communicating what
the business logic of my application is
trying to do
and once more
everything is explicit
and declared right
i can
inspect that kind member
and look at each one of those by the way
the strings here would be autocompleted
in your editor right and when the moment
arrives to use
the address well it is accessible
and one piece of uh
of information that you might want to
look into later is that the kind there
is the member that was used for the
union type and this is what it's called
a discriminated union so if you want
some jargon for you a discriminated
union where i am using a single field
across different types kind
to make a discrimination to know which
of them i am accents accessing right now
so you can then
go it later discriminate a union so
that's it
all right
what happened with my data
anyone wants to take a crack of what
immutability is
shout out
no so
immutability um if you have in
javascript typescript either
as well uh an object
that object can be changed at any given
time right you create a new instance of
an object you can access its members and
change it in many programming languages
functional programming languages
specifically
that doesn't happen right you have an
instance of a type you cannot ever
change that type you have to create a
new one
in javascript we're gonna soon have
probably records and tuples that are
going to be data structures that are
immutable by default we don't have those
right now but we have some things that
we can do with javascript with
typescript to make sure that we're
communicating that using our code is
safe using our types is safe for
instance in this function here i'm
taking an array and i'm saying okay this
array here is read only so if you pass
down your array to me
i'm not going to change our array in
place so if i call push pop or reverse
on an array we're changing that array in
place sort is another one that is very
common that we do
and it's changing the array in place but
if i have that read-only keyword there
i'm telling to everybody using this
function here this is safe don't worry
about i'm not don't worry about it i'm
not going to change your array
that's good
for
arrays but
for for types and objects that doesn't
work that read-only uh keyword doesn't
do anything what you can do is use a
generic type right but the problem with
that one is that
it's not going to look at the nested
in-depth
objects right so i can make it
order.rtid
read-only but order the customer the
customer id is not so that can be
changed how can we solve that we can
create our own immutable type with
typescript
and
this here is a very intense and dense
type of type script
called some typescript code
don't worry about it you don't need to
understand what's going on but what is
making is it's
allowing me to create insta
object types that are immutable in depth
with all its nested members so i can
create something like this i can create
a type order that is now always
immutable and it's going to be immutable
in that with all its nested members so
i and i can even do that
when i'm receiving my arguments right so
i'm again communicating to folks that i
either have an order type
in this case here oh sorry
i either have another type that
throughout its whole existence in my
code base it is immutable or i can tell
folks that inside of this function here
order is always immutable and then when
i'm trying to make any kind of change to
that order i cannot type script is not
going to allow me to do so
all right we're almost there some final
thoughts and a quick recap
first off
compiled code doesn't get stale so if
you can communicate what you're trying
to achieve with types that's a good
thing comments well
they not they don't always work right
they may get stale so that's the problem
with the comments use your comments with
the why you're doing what you're trying
to do not with what you're trying to do
think about the next person when you're
writing your code or
yourself right
and
if that piece of code looks like some
kind of magic try to make it explicit
try to tell people what it's trying to
do create types for it communicate what
you're trying to do
be honest about your function signatures
if it is returning something
down so
if it is returning a
an error tell them so if may not return
a value
tell your user that you may not return a
value
and any
is not a escape hatch for you to do
anything at all with your types right if
you don't know what what you're trying
to do use unknown just
don't patch it with any that's not what
it's for
limit the scope of your strings if you
have a limited set of strings that means
you have a limited set of cases you need
to handle you don't need to handle all
possible cases with strings
especially if you know that your
business logic has some states that
you need to define try to get
sorry try to create types that represent
that uh having that being checked at
compile time is going to be easier for
you later
again i work at shopify we're hiring
we use typescript you can work remotely
if you want to
and that's it thank you
awesome thank you